okay moving on to this late last week
marked a significant occasion um at
least an occasion that we're supposed to
believe is significant it was the 25th
anniversary of the death of Matthew
Shepard and the media and many on the
left published their tributes to uh
Matthew Shepard who they say of course
uh and have been saying for two and a
half decades now was the victim of a
barbaric anti-gay hate crime that's what
they say and so there are a lot of
examples I could show you of of the left
uh talking about this and and talking
about Matthew Shepard and a lot of
tweets a lot of Articles and and you
know video tributes and all the rest of
it so here's just one one example this
is from The Daily Beast it says um in
his 1968 speech at the National cathedal
Cathedral Martin Luther King Jr
proclaimed that the Ark of the moral
universe is long but it bends towards
Justice well that may be true there are
Peaks and valleys along that path
especially when it comes to tolerance
for and acceptance of those who don't
fit into traditional roles and paradigms
consequently reminders of past
injustices and the need to keep fighting
for equality and compassion remain ever
relevant that's why investigation
discovery is commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the murder of Matthew
Shepard with a heartfelt documentary
about his life his slaying and the
impact it had on a movement dedicated to
achieving freedom for all premiering
October 9 October 9th the Matthew
Shepard Story an American hate crime is
a look back at a yesterday that feels
long ago and yet also not so far away
its story is W that in 1998 made
national headlines it helped drive a
campaign for hate crime legislation and
in the process a wide range of lgbtq
plus rights that it took a horrific
homicide to Spur such changes continues
to be a sad commentary about how civil
liberties are acquired sadder still
though is this documentary's Koda about
the potential limits of progress and the
uh consequent uh uh necessity of pushing
back against the omnipresent forces of
malicious
bigotry now it goes on from there uh to
tell the story of how Shephard was
targeted for his sexuality and and
viciously murdered because of it in fact
we have a clip from um uh that that
investigation discovery put out from
their documentary which is just someone
reading a letter uh from Matthew Shepard
um to show what a great guy he was and
how sad it all is let's play that
[Music]
clip hey Mom I'm writing to say hello
how is
everything I've been okay kind of
homesick having trouble with getting
into this swing of
things but it won't last long I
hope I've been real depressed and I
think it's let down I came back and the
weather was
crummy and I miss
home miss you love
Matt okay so we got the dramatic music
in the background reading the letter um
reading the letter from Matthew sheer
like he some sort of a great historical
figure um and this is all part of the
same narrative again that that Matthew
Shepard was uh a is a martyr for gay
rights and he was killed for being gay
and the problem of course with that
narrative is that it's a total absolute
lie okay and it and it's still somehow
it still surprises me that there are
people out there lots of people who
don't know that this was a lie and I was
tweeting about it yesterday uh briefly
and I heard from a lot of people of
course a lot of people on the left who
were uh even they don't can't deny that
it's a lie but instead they just get mad
at you for talking about it and but even
there are many other people not on the
left who say well I hadn't heard this
before I didn't realize it's the first
time hearing it I always thought Matthew
Shepard um so and I don't blame them
it's just this just shows how uh the
left's control of information while it
has been compromised in recent years uh
because of you know the the internet and
social media and all that it's it it's
they still largely control the spread of
information and therefore largely have
the ability to decide to determine our
own history and how we view our own
history um and uh events in history
including events that were not all that
long ago so uh the narrative about in
case you didn't know this if you heard
about Matthew she everyone heard about
Matthew Shepard and uh I you know in my
generation I graduated high school in
2004 and Matthew Shepard uh murder was
in um in what was it in
1998 so you know I'm I'm right in the
generation where they really they they
hit us hard they hit us very hard with
the Matthew Shepard thing and I was told
well I was remember hearing about this
in
school and they would tell us about what
a terrible hate crime it was and of
course when I was a kid in school I I
believed it I didn't you know I didn't
question
um but we know now that all that is
untrue now the only thing that's true is
that he was murdered yes so he's he was
a person who was murdered he's one of
the thousands of murder victims that
that we've had in this country over the
last 25 years um but what we know now
and what we've known for a long time and
this again is not in
dispute is that he was not killed for
being gay this was a drug rated dispute
Matthew Shepard was a drug dealer he was
a dealer wasn't just dealing any drug he
was dealing meth okay he was dealing
straight
poison um and his murderers were also
drug
dealers and they were gay too so Matthew
Shepard was a gay drug addict and drug
dealer and and he had even had uh had
previous sexual encounters with at least
one of his
Killers so he was killed by a former gay
lover um because he was a drug drug
dealer not because he's gay that's the
fact okay it's it it's it's it is not
despite what the left says it is not
dangerous to be gay in this
country at least you're not going to be
you're not going to be killed for
it there are uh other dangers Health
dangers and so
on uh but there you're not going to be
hunted down and killed for it now if
you're a meth dealer on the other hand
that is a very dangerous
occupation now you are in a world uh
with people who by definition don't care
about the law are are very often very
violent
people and this is the world you're in
now and so Matthew Shepard is one of the
many meth dealers and drug dealers who
have been killed I mean that's the now
is it as I said when I talked about this
on
Twitter um again it's it's revealing
that when you bring this the left they
won't even most of them won't deny what
I'm saying not directly because they
know they can't it's just they know they
can't um instead they'll you know
they'll just label you a homophobe well
how dare you bring this up in the first
place um or they'll try some they'll
they'll try to well that doesn't mean
the death isn't sad and shouldn't be
remembered you
know every uh every murder is is sad in
its own way I
suppose but first of all I got to be
honest with you I don't spend a lot of
time uh mourning the deaths of meth
dealers I I kind of feel like you get
into that line of work then uh and it
and and ultimately it claims your life
well that's on you it's a terrible thing
the whole thing is of course it's sad
it's sad that somebody would get into
dealing math in the first place the
whole thing is sad said I I I wish that
nobody would I wish that Matthew Shepard
had lived a a more productive life and
he was still alive to this day but uh
but he's not the G20 or group of 20 is
an international forum for governments
and Central Bank Governors it was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability well last month the G20
announced a plan to impose digital
currencies and digital IDs on their
respective populations Central Bank
digital currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies that
closely you should be concerned about
this and you should consider
diversifying at least some of your
assets into physical gold with the help
of Birch gold group call Birch gold
today to preserve your savings in a tax
sheltered retirement account if you have
an IRA or 401K from a previous employer
that's just Gathering dust will call
Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you won't
pay a penny out of pocket they simply
convert that 401k that's just sitting in
a bank somewhere into physical gold
which can't be tampered with text Walsh
to 9898 98 and Birch gold will send you
a free info kit on gold if digital
currency becomes a reality you'll be
glad you have something physical to fall
back on text Walsh to
9898917350 the only reason we know
Matthew Shepard's name only reason is
because of the story that was made up
about him if not for that story nobody
would remember his
name if this story was never
invented and I came to you out of
nowhere and said hey you know 25 years
ago this meth dealer was killed in a
pretty brutal fashion uh by some of his
meth dealing buddies isn't that a
terrible tragedy you'd look at you'd
look at me with like a blank expression
you'd say you'd say well I mean it's
always sad when someone's killed but I
what do you why are we talking about
this now people die every day like why
is that a special
tragedy the only again the only reason
anyone knows his name is because of the
story that was made up which is why it
is anytime his his name is brought up it
is always relevant to point out oh you
know the only reason you're talking
about him you know that the only reason
it's a it is a
lie
and yet in spite of these facts the
media still pushes Shephard as a
martyr now it's true if you if you uh
refute it and say well here's what
actually happened they're not most of
them will not try to argue with you
because they know they
can't but they'll still push it
anyway they know it's not true anyone
who's research this case knows it's not
true and they push it and I think that
that shows us two things number one
that the left and neither of these are
uh Revelations really but the
left remains committed to their false
narratives to the end they will they
never let go of their false narratives
they will they will stay committed to
them
forever Never Let It
Go um this is the kind of consistency
that they
have it's it's it's a bad consistency
because are consistently
liars and they stick to a
lie but they are Relentless and that is
one of the reasons why the left has been
successful uh in the culture War why not
just successful but it's why they they
have it's why they own the culture the
culture even to this point is still
theirs and we as conservatives are kind
of uh you know we are the sort of
Guerilla fighters in this culture War
because we we don't we don't have power
over any of the
institutions they have all the
institutional power and this is one of
the ways that they achieved
it by establishing their narrative
establishing their story and sticking to
it always no matter what at any
cost so that's one thing we learned from
the other thing is that
um leftism as I've said many times is
essentially a
religion
and it's a religion of self- worship
which is another way of saying that it's
Satanism you know it's kind of a secular
Satanism
um
and uh a cult maybe we would be a better
word for it and any cult has its
foundational
myths and the leftism is the same way it
has its foundational
myths um and the problem with a
foundational myth is that you can never
really admit that it's a myth because it
lays at the foundation of everything
else that you're saying and doing and if
you admit that it's a myth and it
destabilizes the whole
structure and on the left all of their
foundational myths are based in
victimhood okay like they don't have any
Heroes they don't have anyone that they
admire really for being triumphant and
Victorious all of their
myths are about victimhood all of their
heroes are
victims and and very often these are the
martyrs that they invent are people it's
not even like these are people who died
fighting for a cause it's not like these
are people who lived impressive
lives uh and then were martyred no it's
these are people who did nothing
constructive with their lives in fact
were were were in many cases were
burdens on society drug dealers drug
addicts and then were killed and it's
the manner of their death that the left
finds
useful um or rather I should say it's
what the left can say it's the lie that
the left can make up about the manner of
the death that they find
useful I mean think about it the
the for the race Hustlers on the left
you have the race Hustlers and the
gender
hustlers uh and on the race
Hustlers they're right now their their
number one Saint the highest you know in
the hierarchy in the saintly hierarchy
is George Floyd and then for the gender
Hustlers and you know the the gender and
sexuality wing of leftism um they have
Matthew
Shepard and in one case you have a
violent criminal drug addict in the
other case you have a meth dealer Junkie
and these are the two most blessed most
revered
Saints and in both cases they will look
you in the face and just simply lie to
you about how those people died and
why and if you dare correct them they'll
um recoil in
horror because I we we are supposed to
even if
what they tell you is even if you
realize that what they're saying is a
lie you should still have a hushed
reverence you should have a hushed
reverence because these people are
killed after all so so how dare you so
they they're dead and so that gives us
the right to say whatever we want about
them so if you if you uh dispute their
narrative it is
somehow you're you're disrespecting the
memories of these great
people now I don't know about you but I
think uh when somebody
guys I mean the first and most basic way
that we can respect them whoever they
are is by being honest about who they
were you know when you turn them into
some sort of
mascot um among many other things uh I
would say that that is that's how you
are degrading them and uh and their
memory such as it
is hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there